تعليقا على استشهاد الصحفي حمزه الدحدوح
قال الرئيس العراقي عبد اللطيف رشيد ان ما
تعرض له الصحفي الشجاع وائل الدحدوح
وعائلته من استهداف وقتل تجسيد حي ل ماساه
شعب مظلوم وجدد رشيد مطالبته للمجتمع
الدولي بتحمل مسؤولياته القانونيه
والاخلاقيه والانسانيه تجاه ما يحصل
للفلسطينيين في غزه من جهته قال رئيس
الجزائري عبد المجيد تبون ان اغتيال
الصحفي حمزه الدحدوح استهداف مقصود للاطقم
الاعلاميه وانتهاك للقانون الدولي
الانساني من جانبها قالت الخارجيه
البريطانيه ان وفاه حمزه الدحدوح ومصطفى
ثريا ماساه واشارت الى ان المراسلين الذين
يغطون النزعات يجب ان يتمتعوا بالحمايه
بموجب القانون الانسانيه الدولي واضافت
الخارجيه البريطانيه ان على اسرائيل ان
تضمن ق الصحفيين بعملهم
بامان وقالت الخارجيه الاستراليه ان
استراليا تشعر بقلق عميق زاء العدد المروع
من الوفيات بين المدنيين في غزه بما في
ذلك مقتل العديد من
الصحفيين